[Music]
human touch
we need that touch from the one we love
almost as much as we need air to breathe
I never understood that until I couldn't
have it it never fades away this is my
life with cystic fibrosis that thing out
of my face what would I do without you
you dad
people with CF aren't supposed to get
within six feet because we could end up
catching each other's bacteria you
followed me with the intent of
introducing myself and well lumen you're
the kind of guy that ignores the rules
cuz it makes you feel in control am i
right you're not wrong you think that's
cute do you think it's cute there's no
bra but busy know how lucky you are to
be here nothing is going to save our
lives we're breathing far out air these
meds are not optional yeah that's
probably why they keep shoving them down
my throat okay we're gonna do our
treatments together so that way I know
you're actually doing them check out
funny
[Music]
don't tell me the one time you're
interested in some guy he's also got CIA
I just helped him set up his mad cart I
know you still the organizing a med card
is like flirting six feet apart at all
times both know the rules you catch this
infection and you can kiss new lungs
goodbye I don't want to hurt you this
whole time I've been living for my
treatments instead of doing my treatment
so that I can live and I want to live
after all the CF is stolen for me I
don't mind stealing something back three
hundred four millimeters twelve inches
one foot
[Music]
five feet apart are you in
[Music]
[Applause]
you
six feet at all times you both know the
rules we'll get back to your room there
you go a little name for your
psychological profile I'm well Newman
and you are good still oh thank you for
putting your mask back on
Dell uh you need to lighten up it's just
life it'll be over before you know it
hey my lungs are darts okay can you just
let me enjoy this view well I can't do
you know how lucky you are to be here
to be a part of this drug trial how do
you know about my drug trial you've been
asking about me if you don't care then
leave give your spot to someone else
someone that that wants it that wants to
live
what are you doing well well no please
keep down we'll stop please God
fine stay up here then why did I pack
anything nice Oh cuz you always pack for
a hot Hospital romance
[Music]
this see-through
[Music]
hey I'm Justin Baldoni director of
liable party we are currently flying
we're gonna be surprising three
audiences who are watching five feet
large that has no idea that false brows
I can't eat the richest I'm gonna walk
in and watch movies and dream the one
day having
[Applause]
one foot just one foot closer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you